well the shadow Health secretary West
streeting is with us this morning good
morning how are you how would labor deal
with the migrant crisis
drop the gimmicks and focus on three
specific things one is speeding up the
speed at which decisions are made on
applications so fewer than one percent
of small boat arrivals applications have
been processed in the last year that's
unacceptable secondly send people back
immediately when their claims are failed
the numbers there are down eighty
percent compared to when labor left
office uh 13 years ago and thirdly we've
got to smash these criminal gangs many
of them as Sky News has found are based
here in our country and sometimes this
challenge is about working with other
countries but sometimes these are
problems of our own making and we can't
blame the French for our failed
bureaucracy we can't blame the Germans
for the fact that we've got criminal
gangs operating in our country that
we're not dealing with instead of
wasting what will end up being hundreds
of millions of pounds on a fail Rwanda
scheme let's put that money into the
National Crime agency to sweep these
people off our streets and get them
behind bars so they can stop exploiting
vulnerable people trying to get to Safe
Haven easier said than done if it was
that easy the government would have done
it they would say you think's okay but
they keep on going after these headline
grabbing gimmicks that won't work I mean
take this proposal that anyone arriving
via small boat should be given a blanket
ban well firstly how are they going to
identify these people for the future
they're going to tattoo their forehead
saying not welcome in Britain so that we
recognize that they come back under a
different name I don't think so secondly
we know that there have been people
who've come via small boats from
Afghanistan even though there's meant to
be a safe route who are veterans who
have fought for this country are we
going to say oh sorry mate I know you
fought for Britain but back you go
because you've come via a small boat and
sometimes I know it's not as exciting as
the headlines the government's trying to
create but getting the processes right
is important I mean the fact that we've
only had 22 people come via the Afghan
race settlement scheme Pathway to
compared to eight more than eight and a
half thousand who've come via small
boats tells us that the systems the
government government are putting in
place aren't working and they should
roll their sleeves up and focus on
solving the problem rather than
generating headlines in the hope the
voters will be duped into thinking the
government after 13 years are going to
get this right well the PM says she's
going to do that and we'll find out what
the detail is later on this week in the
meantime we'll also be finding out
what's going on with Sue gray hmm when
did Sue gray start talking to secure I
don't know is the honest answer she's
going to have to disclose that as part
of the have you asked the question no I
have enough spoken to care over the
weekend but um Sue gray is going to have
to disclose that as part of the process
this is not new Ed Llewellyn who was
David Cameron's chief of staff was a
senior Diplomat before going to work for
David Cameron and then went down a prime
minister in the process but nodded too
gray actually apparently she was asked
by Boris Johnson to do
um an inquiry he lauded her Integrity
when he asked her to do it as have by
the way many decent conservatives in
recent days said hang on a minute you
know conservative colleagues calm down
this is not unusual and she is is a
professional civil servant who's worked
well with lay brand conservative
ministers she's not breached confidences
there's no reason to expect she'll do so
now I can understand why there's some
sour grapes that good people are now
wanting to work with labor because
they're hoping and thinking we might be
the next government Joan a prime
minister I don't think that's a fair
characterization okay the person who
brought down Boris Johnson was Boris
Johnson unless she packed the booze into
the suitcase and wheeled it into number
10.
I think that she's a labor supporter
otherwise she wouldn't want to work for
um secured armor
we are attracting lots of support from
people who've previously voted
conservative or people who previously
worked for the conservatives uh you know
as Ian Anderson um their former LGBT
advisor for example I think good people
across the political Spectrum are in
despair at this government and their
failure and their dishonesty and their
lack of integrity and are wanting to
help build the alternative and for a
party that's serious about going from
opposition to government as labor is we
want to make sure that all the policies
that we commit to come work in practice
that we've we are well prepared to hit
the ground running on day one because
this country's problems are so big at
the moment that we're not going to have
time to waste finding our feet we're
going to have to get cracking on day one
then sue gray will help us do that she's
got a process to go through we've got to
let that process take it so when did I
very much hope when do you feel she
became disillusioned with this
government I don't know you'd have to
ask her I'm asking you but I don't know
I'm not a mind reader I think I've met
Sue gray once off the top of my head um
so I don't I don't know is the honest
answer so you up until we broke the news
I think on Friday you were not aware
that Sue gray might be the next chief of
staff nope wow I'm not you know I'm not
involved in case Chief of Staff so
secure Starman does not communicate with
his top table about who might be the
next chief of staff I would not expect
here to ask for my approval or anyone
else's or something like disgusting who
might be no I think I think I think I
think here was very very clear with the
shadow cabinet and with the with the
wider team that what he was looking for
in the next chief of staff was someone
who could do the serious work on
preparation for government we've got a
campaigns director for the general
election who's focused on winning the
election I think Kia wants his chief of
staff to focus on the serious work of
preparing for government so that frankly
we don't end up in the shambolic mess of
the conservatives who even after 13
years of practicing still don't seem to
have got it right
let's wait and see how that story
develops can you at least acknowledge
that the Optics are not great
I don't think I don't think anyone
really cares beyond the world
come on Beyond some foaming at the mouth
lunatics on the conservative right who
are looking for any excuse to
rehabilitate Boris Johnson because they
hate Rishi think rishi's stabbed he put
together a report that this previous
prime minister could not come back from
now she's decided to walk across the
divide and represent what if I may and
and represent your leader who may be the
next prime minister but when the Sue
gray report was published Boris Johnson
basically claimed it was some sort of
vindication of his position we all knew
it was I don't know you can't have your
cake and eat it but neither can Boris
Johnson hang on a second I don't think
there's anything that we've seen or
heard that suggests that she's not a
professional civil servant who behaves
with the utmost Integrity don't just
take my word for it or indeed former
labor cabinet ministers who work for a
people like George Osborne former
Chancellor Francis Maude who led the
cabinet office dealt heavily with the
Civil Service and with Sue Gray
I don't think anyone would have had a
clue as to her politics listening to the
people who've described working with her
and this just to be clear about the type
of role that kirstama wants to do it is
about preparing for government making
sure that labor can work effectively
across the Civil Service and pulling the
right levers of government to affect the
kind of change that we want to see in
our country that's not the same as being
a but you know a campaigns director
trying to win the general but she may
find herself in a position where she
can't take up that role for up to two
years well I think we'd expect there to
be a period of gardening leave I think
that's normal in these sorts of
situations where you don't jump to your
next election straight from one job to
another but let's say there's a process
to follow and I hope that Rishi sunak
will ignore the lunatic fringes of his
party I mean I know he struggles to do
that on a daily basis anyway but I hope
that he will do the right thing behaving
the proper way as as other Prime
Ministers as a position would be there
is a proper process to go through let's
let Sue gray go through that process and
let's hope that she's able to make sure
the label the government can hit the
ground running on day one because that's
our ambition Just Before I Let You Go
maternity Wards that's what you want to
talk about yeah so we've got a massive
problem at the moment 16 maternity Wards
having to close at points last year
because of a shortage of Staff that's
one in three at the heart of this is a
chronic shortage of midwives leaving the
profession faster than we can recruit
them in many cases so we've got to do
two things one is retain The Midwives
which is why the pay negotiations this
week are so important secondly we've got
to embark on the biggest expansion of
NHS staff in history labor has a plan to
do that fully costed fully funded double
the number of medical school places 10
000 nursing and Midwifery clinical
training places funded by abolishing and
on Dom tax dates are plan so good that
even Jeremy Hunt himself said that this
government should Nick it on the base
that smart governments make the best
ideas of their opponent